- [Voiceover] No more commuting.
(whooshing)
(light upbeat music)
- [Woman In The Bathroom]
You left the seat up again.
(sighs blowing lips)
(lid slams down)
(door slams)
(light upbeat music)
(whooshing)
- Do you know what this means?
- I can go skiing
without buying lift tickets.
Check the weather in Aspen.
Yeah so I was flying yesterday
and saw this crazy go--
- Oh my gosh Eli, we get it,
you can fly, stop bragging.
- Sorry y'all.
- It's annoying man.
- Well saki bombs in Japan in 10 minutes.
See ya.
(jumping propulsion)
- You know I can play guitar
but you don't hear me bragging about it.
- Wanna go to John's or a club or a bar,
or what do you wanna...
- Look who made it to town for Halloween.
- Holy shit cuz, come in.
So what did you get me for Christmas?
- Ho, ho, ho, Santa's in town.
Guess who?
- Again, can you call first?
It's Valentines day.
(drinking)
(muffled chatting)
- [Voiceover] Ladies, ladies, ladies.
- I agree.
(humming)
- Jared you were without a doubt
the most qualified
candidate for this promotion
so we're gonna give it to you.
- Mother fucker!
(zapping out of view)
- Hey Venita, nice to finally meet you.
How are you?
- I'm good.
- Why is she not wearing sandals?
I wanna see her feet.
- I just remembered that
I left my dishwasher on,
so I gotta go.
- [Man's Thoughts] I should just face it,
I'll never have the
courage to ask her out.
Too much of a nerd.
- [Pink Haired Woman's Thoughts]
I only asked for that pen
so in could look deeply into his eyes.
- Just ask her.
- [Dog's Thoughts] Puny human,
all dogs are actually aliens
here to destroy the Earth.
We are going to burn
your entire civilization,
and you are the only human
being I've told this to.
We've hypnotized every last one of 'em.